mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces
membranes la scène où tyrannosaure cris
face caméra juste après avoir balancé
les voitures par dessus l'enclos qu'est
ce que c'est que ces membranes qui
prennent tant de place dans sa bouche
et bien c'est intéressant c'est une
histoire intéressante parce que avant
jurassic park finalement la
représentation de sept de ses deux
membranes elle était assez rare au final
a évidemment il suffit que je le dise
pour qu'on me trouve des tas de contre
exemple parce que c'est vrai qu'il y à
des contre exemples il ya des tas
d'artistes de paléo artistes qui avaient
représenté ces membranes chez des
dinosaures carnivores avant jurassic
park
mais après jurassic park la
représentation de ces membranes est
devenue la norme
et ça c'est très intéressant comme
phénomène et c'est arrivé pour plein
d'autres choses notamment pour la
position de la que représentait un
dinosaure bipède qui n'a pas la queue
qui traînent au sol
c'est pas jurassic park qui l'a inventé
mais clairement c'est après jurassic
park que c'est devenu la norme
et je me rappelle quand j'étais petit
avant jurassic park mais dinosaures qui
avait la queue qui traînait par terre je
m'en fichais mais après jurassic park
c'était hors de question que je joue
avec parce que parce que c'était pas des
vrais dinosaures les vrais dinosaures
ils ont pas la queue qui traînent par
terre
et donc voilà c'est c'est ça la force de
jurassic park c'est que avec jurassic
park ya des choses qu'on n'avait pas vu
avant ou presque pas vu avant et qui
sont d'un seul coup devenu la norme ou
des choses qui n'était connu que des
spécialistes et qui sont d'un seul coup
devenu public populaire et ces membranes
en font partie donc ces membranes et
bien ce sont ni plus ni moins que les
muscles mastic ateurs qu'on voit
apparaître à travers la bouche et
pourquoi on les voit apparaître à
travers la bouche parce que les
tyrannosaures n'a pas de joux les
dinosaures de manière générale à part
les herbivores comme le tricératops et
vous ne verrez jamais ces membranes par
exemple sur une représentation de
tricératops iguanodon houda droz or
parce que eux ils ont des joues mais les
dinosaures carnivores comme tyrannosaure
eux ils n'avaient pas de joux et du coup
quand il ouvre la bouche en grand et ben
on voit leur muse
l'instigateur et on peut même voir ses
muscles sur d'autres animaux qui ont des
petites joues qui n'ont pas des grandes
joutes comme les chiens donc par exemple
sur ce qui vous pouvez voir que il quand
il a la bouche ouverte on voit ses
muscles mastic ateurs donc pour ça
jurassic park est assez intéressant
parce qu'en fait c'est la première fois
aussi qu'on les représenter aussi
proéminent si vous regardez par exemple
le film petits pieds ben vous vous
verrez si vous plisser les yeux très
fort vous arriverez à voir ces mêmes
muscles mastic ateurs ces mêmes membrane
sur dents tranchantes mais ils sont tout
petits et même pas aussi bien représenté
en sur différents plans en fait donc ils
sont pas très cohérent entre les plans
des fois ils y sont des fois ils sont
pas vous regarder des vieux produits
culturels des vieux films de dinosaures
ils n'y sont jamais mais mais dans
jurassic park dans le et sur le
tyrannosaure en particulier ses muscles
masticatoire ils sont très très grands
ils s'étendent jusqu'en dessous de
l'oeil mais il n'empêche que ça illustre
bien comment jurassic park a défini le
nouveau canon de ce qu'est un dinosaure
pour le grand public
ça définit parfaitement le pouvoir qu'a
jurassic park sur l'éducation cahu
jurassic park 1 sur l'éducation
paléontologique donc jurassic park à ce
pouvoir d'éduquer les gens il a ce
pouvoir de changer complètement la
perception qu'on a des dinosaures avec
jurassic park la queue qui traînent au
sol c'était fini pour de bon avec
jurassic park on est passé d'une
représentation sporadiques de ses
muscles mastic à terre à une
représentation systématique des muscles
mastic ateurs chez les théropodes et
c'est précisément pour ça que ça fait
râler autant de monde qu'on mette pas de
plumes sur les dinosaures de jurassic
world parce que jurassic la saga
jurassic park la saga jurassic world
elle a ce pouvoir de montrer la science
est de rendre la science aussi populaire
qu'elle peut l'être
elle a ce pouvoir et la saga jurassic
world n'a pas eu de respect pour ce
pouvoir est maintenant il nous a échappé